what the hell is that
Batman and Harley Quinn I have no idea
what I just watched it it wasn't good
I'm having a hard time actually
gathering my thoughts to form an opinion
on this thing it's not good that I will
say that absolutely it's not good but
the way in which it's bad is really
weird it's not like say all the new 52
based DC animated movies that are bad
because the characters are all grumpy
and suck and the action is dull and
boring and and and stuff like that it's
not those infuriate me because at this
point they are bad in a very predictable
way this was bad but I would not have
called the ways and this is bad which
made it oddly fascinating and I'm not
sure I'd go so far as to recommend it
but if you are somebody who tends to
watch a lot of the DC Animated stuff not
only would I not warn you off it I would
actively encourage you to watch it
because this is madness so I get they'll
be spoilers I guess except the story is
really kind of inconsequential and very
easy to figure out I mean it plays out
as far as plot goes is basically not any
more complicated than a two-parter out
of the Batman animated series would have
been but God where do I even start um
I'll get the voice cast the guy Kevin
Conroy back they got the the guy who was
Robin who knew who later did Nightwing
for the TV show he's back there there
would ruas good there IV is good there
Harley is not bad
I don't know this actress it's her first
time voicing hardly so far as I could
find and she's not bad at it but she's
certainly she doesn't hold a candle to
the staple she's no Arleen Sorkin and
Tara Strong
who basically more or less took the role
over once Arleen Sorkin kind of left it
behind is better then this woman was so
why they didn't just get terrorists
wrong and I have no idea and again she's
not bad but I've heard much better
Hartley's in audio form so when one of
your title characters is one of the
weaker voice aspects that's not a good
start but then just the tone on this
thing I I don't even know how to
describe the tone on this thing because
it has a light and fun feel like some
episodes of the Batman animated series
did in fact have yet at the same time
there's swearing and there's bloody
deaths in a few cases like I was giving
total whiplash right off the bat we're
after the opening we see would drew the
floor otic man really blood 'le murdered
this guard and then they have this this
title sequence is basically like a road
walk run or cartoon with with Harley
playing you know the Road Runner and
tricking everybody into hurting
themselves and I'm watching this title
sequence going this does not feel like
it belongs to the start of the movie we
just got and that kind of it's all over
the place cuz we this is a movie that
ends on a joke and fails to properly
resolve the story in the end has things
like it pulls out of nowhere middle of
the movie it decides to run with gags of
the visible young pow sock whatever you
know riffing on the Adam West Batman and
one of them is all my balls and yet at
the same movie that has a scientist who
is not a recurring character and he's
not an important guy in the DC Universe
but he gets killed and there's this long
lingering thing on him dying in this
dramatic music and Harley's really torn
up about it and it seems to throw
Nightwing off for the scene that follows
it's like
all of this part of the same movie I
mean there are ways to you know find a
balance but you know with having light
fun but having poignant moments but they
don't blend it's just from seeing the
scene it's doing one thing then it's
doing another and they don't gel like at
all and when it's going for comedy
sometimes it works some of the comedy
works some of the jokes work other times
especially if they're coming off a more
dramatic moment or an attempt at a
dramatic moment it just it falls flat
and then okay I can't not talk about the
Harley and Nightwing thing because what
what the hell bruised him what the hell
okay you didn't learn your lesson from
going needlessly sexualized with
batgirls additional scenes in The
Killing Joke you had to do with Harley
now too great did there's better
precedent for Harley being over
sexualized but again total all over the
place because we're getting you know
lighting goofy moments and then she
strips down to her underwear literally
out of nowhere for no reason other than
fanservice and she bends over looking in
the closet and then decides she's gonna
wait why any of this cuz it's just so
weird because like I said in some ways
the tone is reminiscent of some of the
lighter episodes of the Batman animated
series and yet at the same time it
throws in all this all the most
superficially mature things that can ie
swearing sexual content bloody violence
and it just comes off as way more
childish and juvenile then that TV show
ever did and it's just it's the things
all over the map the scene at the bar
which had the one visual gag that I
liked which is that it's full if you if
you actually really know the Batman
animated series really well that bar
where there's the dance scene and going
on it is loaded with actual
background henchmen characters those
twins the big clown those were the ones
I recognized off the bat I'm sure most
of them were were from the TV show I
thought that was cool and clever it
didn't draw a ton of attention itself
and that was nice
why didn't we have like two full song
sequences in there Harleys I kind of
maybe get I mean it served no plot
function but like okay give her a moment
why were we focusing on the twins and
their number they should have been just
in the background providing ambience why
didn't we basically stopped everything
dead to have this extended song sequence
with them and then immediately followed
up with Harley's it feels like filler it
feels like they were short on runtime
and they decided to just do that okay
that'll eat up a few minutes I suppose
and it's the things like trying to have
the world ending stakes and yet keeps
blowing these jokes and again you can
have high world-ending stakes and get
jokes in there something like Kingsman
did that very well but even the first
Kingsman movie which was the one that
did it better
knew that when you are barreling towards
that climax you need to have it more
focused on the action and the stakes and
let the humor kind of fall to the
background until Kingsman did that one
joke at the very end that it would take
to everybody off but that's another
subject in any case this thing just even
as it gets into the climax with the
world ending stakes just back forth back
forth you know dramatic death and then
just goofy joke huh and like the kid the
whole thing hardly an IV it worked
pretty well but why did hardly like
betray Batman and Nightwing for like a
hot second was it just so she could have
the line you know I did what you thought
it would cuz it's Thursday and like god
and then there are some jokes that work
but I think the one that that landed the
best for me if I'm gonna like highlight
a good well-executed joke is there is an
extended chase scene where Harley you
know Harley is he's riding in the
Batmobile and she tells them hey stop we
gotta get that guy and she goes out this
extended chasing goes on maybe a little
longer
than it should and I'm going here why is
this going on so long she gets this guy
and it turns out it was a guy who stood
her up at a dance and high school that's
the oh that was her only interest in him
that was good that was funny you know
why because that was a comedic moment
informed by character not weird tonal
shifts in the whole overall thing it was
a moment that was funny because it spoke
to Harley as a character and just that
this thing is just bizarre it is so
weird and it doesn't work but I kind of
recommend seeing it for just the just
just so you can say you did cuz even my
ranting rambling about this I'm not sure
I can do how bizarre and strange and
just what this thing is
even in this rant and I think in an odd
way you have to experience it for
yourself just don't expect an actual
good movie so this is Batman and Harley
Quinn so have you seen this thing what
were your thoughts on it there's tons of
stuff in here I didn't even talk about
any other moments you want to highlight
that left you sitting there going what
is going on whatever they are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
Council of geese give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast that is
available on iTunes and stitcher I'm
also one half of the punch like a girl
podcast that is a presentation of the
fire and water podcast network at fire
and water podcast.com as for me I'll be
back as soon as I can get my next fix
[Applause]
[Applause]